can you hear me hello yep all right
thank you for joining us I know it's the
last session of the day so thank you for
hanging on it's gonna be an awesome talk
introduce myself my name is Anil Dhawan
I'm a product manager on the Google
cloud launcher emphasis and I belay I
guess I'm a software engineer from
Seattle working on deployment manager
and couple of other cloud convict things
so what we're going to talk about today
is this concept of no more dead software
deployment you know I think we all know
that deploying software is already hard
enough anyone disagree okay Oh got one
people dissenters we should talk
deploying software is already hard
enough but it turns out when you move
into cloud deploying your infrastructure
can often be harder and so what we're
going to do today is talk about some of
the philosophies that have emerged over
time especially when it comes to cloud
to make this easier and we're going to
show you some of the tools we've built
on the Google cloud platform that you
can use to implement those philosophies
to make sure that you're no longer
deploying dead software and then finally
we're going to show you some of the
improvements we've done to the Google
cloud launcher product that integrate
and tie it all together okay so for the
first time in cloud you have this
unprecedented ability to spin up a whole
host of resources from virtual machines
to firewalls to disks in one zone across
multiple zones around the world that's
fantastic and what happens is when you
get these powerful tools that let you
spin up these resources in a matter of
minutes is you tend to use it a lot
right you no longer constrained are
confined to plugging in Ethernet cables
and managing your data center so you're
now trying to do different things you
might be experimenting with a staging
cluster in one environment you might be
ramping up a production customer cluster
in a different zone and that's exciting
it leads to complex architectures but
also gives you some great benefits like
agility you can finally
take an idea put it into practice see if
it works and if it doesn't tear it down
not not about cost to it so a
flexibility get is fantastic but as
Spiderman was told with all that power
comes a great sense of responsibility so
great you spun up all of these resources
and you've SSH into those machines and
you've tuned that kernel parameter to
make sure that I ops are going to be
great but now when you want to move to a
larger system or scale down or replicate
that setup what do you do and so the
default state is what we call dead
software and it's software comes about
because you've lost control of what you
did you created these unique snowflakes
and they were great when they were there
but you no longer know how to get back
to it and what this means is if you're
not going to have a way to get back into
that configuration repeatedly you're
going to be vulnerable because your
software is going to go out of date and
you're going to get things like
configuration drift because what you had
in your mind is not what's running in
production well as you can imagine some
people have tried to solve these
problems and there are tools that do so
but they're not a whole lot better in
terms of solving a problem and I think
what they lead to is potentially
something worse than dead software and
that is zombie software what these tools
try to do is they try to patch a running
environment to try to keep it up-to-date
in concept that's great but we all know
the reality is when you're patching a
running system you're never going to be
able to make it work one hundred percent
of the time well when it fails it's
really difficult to roll back its
equivalent to China change the tires on
a car well to running it's something you
probably wouldn't want to do so great so
we've seen this is we've seen this kind
of model happen in the on-prem world and
you when you move it a cloud this
problem becomes exacerbated so there's
got to be a better solution right well
turns out there is and it's actually
quite fascinating in the last few years
this pattern has emerged around
immutable infrastructure and if you saw
the spinnaker talk today you know
exactly what I'm talking about and the
goal of immutable infrastructure is to
say hey let's no longer change the tires
while the car
running let's instead take all the
components that comprise your
application bundle them up into one
immutable image you can do this through
the notion of a bakery and this whole
process is code developed in the
industry externally we've seen folks
like spinnaker with an by Netflix but
also internally at Google we've been
doing these patterns ourselves for
several years with orb or config and
mitis so this is great once you have an
immutable software package you have an
atomic unit that you know is good you
can trust it but that's only part of the
battle you've got this atomic unit but
now you want to make sure that you can
repeatedly deploy it in a multitude
environments right there aren't many
tools that can do that really well and
that's what I'm going to talk to you
about today which is how do you
implement immutable infrastructure on
Google cloud platform we're going to
show you our tool of implementing this
philosophy it's called deployment
manager and we're going to walk through
a set of examples of how to get a quick
vm up and running and then showing you
some more complexity and building it up
over time so what we want to config a
configuration and management of
infrastructure is a few things and kind
of a very high level one is you want
repeatable deployments you want to know
that the code you're running is going to
match the infrastructure you have in
mind next is you want to be able to take
that same code and reproduce it in
different environments as you scale and
finally but perhaps most importantly you
want a single tool and model to describe
and deploy these things you don't want
to have to change what you do because
you're now deploying Google
infrastructure versus your own resources
or if their parties resources and this
is really where deployment manager comes
in okay so what is deployment manager
deployment manager is our tool in Google
cloud platform to create repeatable item
potent deployments okay it's got a
simple yamel based so human readable
description language with gin gin Python
code behind so it's extremely flexible
and as I said before it can configure
any gcp resource type so you're no
longer constrained to just vm
we can do Cooper Nettie's App Engine IP
addresses firewalls the whole range and
we've got a great g-cloud command line
built-in what deploy matter gives you is
resource configuration that you can
treat like source code you conversion
control it you can share it you can
understand the evolution over time and
these it uses these declarative
templates described in llamo and what
those give you are these repeatable
infrastructure deployments that you use
on the g-cloud command line all of these
things put together with these templates
and the command line integration is
allows you to think a much higher level
of abstraction and in fact as will show
you today you can start describing parts
of your architecture as components and
start using those in consuming those
components with higher level building
blocks all of this put together gives
you what we call living software
deployments and so I'm going to turn
over to belay who's going to show us
deployment manager in action switch over
to the demo thanks and mail okay very
good so I'm going to go ahead and talk a
little bit about very basic things from
the beginning we all faced with very
simple things like how do I get my coat
up and running in the cloud so there's a
couple of ways that you can do this
today as some of you mentioned you can
go ahead and go out there in the bakery
and you can say hey give me an image
whether it's a docker image or whether
it's a VM image doesn't really matter
for this example I'm going to be using
VM images just to keep things simple but
once you have that nicely baked image
you want to go and get it up and running
in the cloud and we certainly have
solutions for you to do this today you
can go up there on the cloud console and
you can go ahead and turn some knobs and
slide some sliders and out pops a vm for
you and that's all great but then if you
want to go and redo that say a week to
five weeks later you come back and
you're like what was it that I do I can
remember you can also do this from the G
glob config g-cloud compute tool you can
go in there and saying hey
I would like to go and spin me up vm
give it some man line flags and out pops
a vm but you're kind of faced with the
same problem again the only thing that
you do have now is maybe a command line
history so you can hopefully spin back
up to it but we can prop with you a
little bit better on that so I'm going
to show you how we can do this with the
deployment manager today so for the
people of manager you go ahead and
create a configuration file it's a
gamble based file it looks like this
it's very simple at the at the top you
say I would like to create some
resources well that's nice then you say
what you would like to create in a
formable is so in this case I want to
create just the same sim single VM
called my vm i give it a type because we
need to know what type you're creating
this one is a vm but as i mentioned it
could be just as well a network load
balancer firewall whatever it is and
then you give it to list of properties
so the properties should look familiar
to you if you have used compute in the
past there's nothing new here they all
look and feel the same because they are
the same because the API is mapped 121
between the underlying resource and what
the deployment manager talks about ok so
i'll give it a zone a machine-type this
case f 1 micro because it's a demo i
give it a desk I want to boot off of
persistent disk using a source image
that I have baked all ready for this
demo it's creatively called nodejs
static cuz i'm not very good with naming
and then i have a network interface i
would like to say please give me a
network interface that i can actually
access from the internet I say give me
an added interface one the one that that
means that it's going to give me an
external IP address ok so using a jew
clock command line tool I can say
mr. diem manager please give me a
deployment and I give it a pointer to my
yeah mofo i also have to give it a name
so let's call it my BM okay so while
that's going on the nice thing is that
because we were able to go ahead and
once we created at yamo file where we
put all these properties into it i can
now go ahead and take that file and i
can put it into source control i can put
it in my github i can keep track of what
changes on that file and when does it
change who made that change and why was
it made that's a really powerful concept
and for this simple case it doesn't
really matter that much but you could
also do things like unit tests right I
could come in there make sure that I
know that I have a step in there that
actually says I'm about to deploy
something how do I know that I'm
actually deep blowing something that
makes sense okay and also remember that
all the properties that i created or
defined in that file we're mapping 1212
my underlying api's so i can go ahead
and use this tool today without having
to understand any new technologies or
any new languages i can just go and take
the properties that i know and love from
the google cloud and just go and create
my list of resources and say please give
me some stuff in the cloud okay so let's
look at this happy little vm we just
created
I'm just a using g-cloud compute tool if
you've used this from the command line
and I'm asking it to describe what my BM
looks like ok so this couple of things
that we really only care about in this
one there's a lot of stuff here but it
was nice that it actually got the
machine type right for me so I wanted an
f1 micro so he created me that that's
nice and it also gave me an external IP
address that i can then go and say curl
against it and it prints surprisingly
hello world right so at this point we
can now go ahead and take this file and
we can go and put it in its part of any
any kind of pipeline that i have and i
can go and tear this thing up and down
all day long I can come back the two
weeks later I can give it to anneal and
I can say hey I know would you like a vm
I would love a vm ok really that's great
but we're Google like if I wanted to
change something let's say I wanted a
larger instance or maybe I want to
change the zone are you telling them
that the best practice is to copy the
file and make the changes and check it
into source code and now have two copies
some of the right thing yeah I'm you
don't have to copy it you can cut and
paste fair enough I mean ok fair enough
for old school that ok it's cool so yeah
so we can certainly go and do that and
we have built in some templating
capabilities in the depot in the manager
and I'm gonna go and show you a little
bit how that would go so let's go ahead
and say that we want to go ahead and run
two stacks so if you have a dev stack
and abroad stat and I want to have a vm
running in both of those and again I'm
going to keep these examples very very
simple just so we can all follow along
and not get cluttered by all kinds of
different conflict but in real world
things will be more complex ok so we can
come in to my handy-dandy Emacs and
again if we look at this file I
temporize it
and the way we do templates is either by
using ginger or using Python for these
examples i'm using ginger but we have
plenty of examples shown Python as well
if that that is what you want to do
notice that the file looks very very
similar to what we had before right so
at the top we have resources because I
would like to create resources I have a
list of them right in this case i only
have again one and for the name I have
just parameterised this I can now say ok
when you can use this template you need
to specify a name and I will use that
name just name my VM I'm still using the
same same tie for my computer with one
instance and then I have again the list
of properties zone doesn't change
because you didn't ask for that but here
is where we introduce a little bit of a
magic here where we can come in and
saying okay I would like to go ahead and
add a new property and a little bit of
program at ability so that I can come in
and saying okay if you'd like to create
the prod environment will give you a
super beefy and one standard to not
really but you know it's better than an
f on micro for this case otherwise just
create me an F 1 micro okay and then the
other parameter that I added is because
we probably want to go and run 2 versus
the different code oronoco and
continuously depot it to my devstack so
I'm going to go and parameterize my
source image so that it's going to go
ahead and boot that vm off of that
source image instead of always hard
coding because you're up don't want to
run the same version of the code in the
same environment and everything else is
the same okay and then to use this I am
going to go ahead and again create a
config file that looks pretty much as i
did before with couple of exceptions one
of them is it has a section at the top
called imports so think about that like
your import statement where you say I
would like to use a different kind of a
tight and I give it the name it's my BM
template ginger and then I give it a
list of resources okay
so in this case the resources again it
looks and feels the same it's going to
make name type and properties but from
my type now i'm using this new type that
i have just created ok so the tide is
the template that i just created a new
type user-defined type with only three
properties ok so i can call and say ok
the name right if you remember that was
the name that is given the underlying vm
and an environment that was an optional
field but in this case we specify it
because we're going to go and run it and
then i'm going to go and give it a
different source image ok so to get this
up and running i'm just going to go
ahead and point to my second file that i
just created the signal v m2 and i'm
gonna give it a different deployment
name because i want to create a proud
environment ok now while that's going
let's go back and look a little bit
about the my template here and the one
thing you might point out is ok well
this is really nice but it's gonna be
very tricky to go and remember how do i
use this template and what are the
properties that i have and while you
could certainly go in and use your crap
powers and everything else to find out
the things you care about we have
introduced a concept of scheme not
scratch there we go where we have a JSON
schema that you can attach to each one
of these templates and types right that
describes what it is that this type does
so I can look at and say uh info ok it's
a single VM template great it's written
by me and there's a description that you
can use and then a version right so you
can keep track of versioning that you
can add in addition to your source
control and then you have a section that
says here are the required parameters
that you must give when you want to
construct one of these types ok so in
this case I only require for you to go
and give me a name and a source image so
i know what the boot right and if you
remember there was an if else clause so
I didn't make the I didn't make the
environment required so it's not as part
of the required list but all the
available properties are then listed in
a section
properties and each one of the
properties is described by what the name
of the properties in this case name a
source image and environment as well as
the type because this could be an int or
whatever else it is and it also has a
description so you can easily inspect
this file and look at it and saying ah
what does this thing do what can you do
for me okay oh yeah you'd finished okay
so now we have a broad friend right so
let's go and look at that a little bit
and again I'm just going to go and
describe that vm
maybe
u.s.
I'm a great typer okay so the machine
came up which is nice and then if we
look at it we can see now that the
machine image has been changed to our
BTW production instance yeah that's nice
and again if i just look at this
external map that was given it i can go
ahead and pink that and see that it's my
production environment right so at this
point i have been able to go ahead and
take this thing again put it in the
github and i can go ahead in case like
this now you can start to see where
you're like okay actually this one I
might want to go and write some unit
tests against it so if i go and specify
property as say as a broad environment i
actually want to go and see this this
kind of a machine spinning up that's
cool that's pretty cool but you know i
know you're a copy and paste guy but
like like a lot of people audience i use
microservices so one vm tu viens is kind
of cute but talk to me about
microservices microservices this guy's
never happening ok so that's great so DM
really lends itself diplo manager
brilliant itself very well to
microservices right because if you if
you start thinking about now the
abstraction so you can create right one
of the examples that I created before
was very very simple right it's a simple
vm that's nice but if you think about it
that you can create any kind of a
resource for you underneath it it could
be a you know highly scaled load
balanced service endpoint for you that
you connect to so the co and demonstrate
that concept i'm going to go ahead and
use again my trusty old vm template
ginger and i'm going to go ahead and run
MongoDB on them ok so again the first
resource in my list doesn't change its
well except with the name but you know
I'm again using my type here that I
created before I'm gonna call it MongoDB
and I booted off my MongoDB image ok
however if you notice i am adding a
secondary resource that I'm creating as
part of this type that I'm running
I am creating a service registry
endpoint here that actually allows me to
go and solve the second prom that I have
been Ivan microservices right so the
first part is i'm going to nicely define
them and saying this is my micro service
and then i'm going to be able to go
ahead and d couple that from the
consumers of that particular service so
in this case what I'm doing is I am
actually producing a service endpoint
that my customers can my customers or
consumers of this service can use ok so
again it is just another gcp resource so
I just specify a type differently from a
vm because i'm not creating a vm and i
give it some properties and the
properties in this case i am just giving
it the address of the MongoDB above but
if you notice I'm using a syntax with
the dollar ref sign here and that is
actually allows me to go ahead and start
creating orchestration so deployment
manager is going to look at this list of
resources it can say ah I can create a
MongoDB because it doesn't really depend
on anything but when it gets down the
[ __ ] DB endpoint it's going to say oh I
need to go ahead and wait before
creating this service registry endpoint
because it depends a MongoDB so DM is
going to go and spin up the vm and then
it's going to go and go back into that
network interface of that MongoDB and
pull that out and then stuff it in the
service registry ok and it also so this
because this is a gcp resource it
actually means that if there's like a
first class citizen you can list your
services you can say hey what are my
services I might have Deb services I'm
at a broad services staging service and
so forth I can create them and delete
them and everything else but the other
nice thing that it does behind the
scenes for you is that it also creates a
DNS entry for you in your GCPD NS ok
sorry GCE dns ok so that means that
without you having to run your own
naming and discovery services this 10
point will be visible through you in the
ens and you can just use this from your
BMS and and crew burn a these clusters
and all of everything's and you can also
restrict the visibility of this endpoint
so that it may be only visible to your
dev network or test Network abort now so
let's go ahead and spin that up
okay so so while that's going on and
it's creating that so let's go and just
step back again and think about the
value that we are able to do now because
we are able to now be able to de couple
the production and consumption of these
services by using the service registry
that's a really powerful concept in
itself the second powerful concept that
we have here is by building these
abstractions I can go ahead and very
easily and with the very high degree of
confidence be able to come in and saying
like when I need to bring up my devstack
no matter how complex it is because I
have treated that source code right it's
checked in somewhere it's got tests
associated with it every time I just go
and spin up these stacks I know that
they are going to come up okay it also
allows me to go and nicely document
these things with the JSON schema we saw
those things right so it was very clear
and easy to go and see how it's used and
so forth so there is it now comes back
and says thank you I created you to
resources like you asked me to so it
created the MongoDB and it also created
a MongoDB endpoint for me okay so let's
go and see what this looks like so in
this case I'm just going to go in ssh
into the machine that i created in the
first case my little single BM
I'll just grab this name in point here
so if you look at this name that we
created here the nice thing about this
name is that it is hard out into its own
namespace so that I can easily go and
say it was the mongodb endpoint its
scope to a project and it's also
separate from your other dns entries so
that there's no kind of collisions
between what other people develop or add
in there anything else so if we just
grab this from here and I'm running in
the vm that i created that had no
knowledge of my handy dandy MongoDB even
existing i can now come in and i can see
it from my from my single VM creating an
iced tea coupling between my services
can we go back to slides okay so let's
go all the way back and think about what
we just started so we started with a
very simple declarative llamo format
right it was really nice and easy we
could just go ahead and come in and look
at all the properties that we already
know if I know VMs I can go and come in
and create my dm's using concepts I
already know ok and the second thing be
added on top of that was ok that's great
but how do I parameterize that how do i
create my own types how do i add
programming in there right so we saw a
little bit of that using ginger
templates again we also support Python
but these examples are using ginger ok
and we created new types so this is
really powerful concept because now what
i can do is instead of thinking about my
cloud resources as just resources I can
start composing the resources that I
want to and put them into github and
describe and declare what it is that
they actually do how do they look like I
can test them and I can really start
treating all of my configuration as code
it should be treated just like code
you'll be happier and then I also showed
you guys how we can go ahead and start
creating microservices build on top of
those abstractions by using the service
registry as a loose coupling mechanism
between the producers of the service and
consumers of the service and so at this
point you might say okay that was great
he showed me a couple of VMS and
everything else but you know in reality
things are believably complex right and
i agree with you they definitely are
very very complex so if you think about
this is a pretty standard kind of a
pattern that we see all the time which
is I might have highly available auto
scale blow balance thingamajig are
running right let's call it my front end
right how would I go and do something
like this in the cloud right it's pretty
complex right well the nice thing is
that by the by us showing you how you
can go ahead and create and reuse some
of these types we've also created a
bunch of these best patterns and best
practices that you should be able to use
right out of the gate and we have many
of these examples in our github that
will show you in just a second and the
second thing is that again in the
production you probably don't want to be
go ahead and just even though you can
reliably go ahead and deploy your
production architecture up and down at
will you probably don't want to go and
tear down your entire infrastructure
because your customers might not be
happy during that so we have a couple of
things that allow us to go ahead and
update parts of our infrastructure like
a rolling up data and can I get back to
my machine just for a moment
so oh that's big okay so what I have
done here is deployed ahead of time
exactly the picture that I just showed
you okay so I have a next demo and then
what i have is i have created a new high
level type called h a service right and
you can see it right there on the top it
says oh you have a h a service that's
great and your h a service is composed
of three things it's got a service
stamped out into two zones but it's just
two instances of the same type and then
on the bottom we have an lb load
balancer ok so now when you look at the
picture that we just showed you and we
look at the actual resources that were
created you can do one-to-one mapping I
saying like oh yeah that's what I
deployed that's nice and then if you
drill down to each one of these things
like let's say our l3 load balancer
you can start to see that at this level
I have a new type where I have taken
three primitive gcp resources I have
wrapped them into one lb 3 load balancer
and I have that hierarchy information
right here so I can come in and I can
see the application how it's built and
then if i look at my service i can see
that i have i have this updated that i
called you before that i mentioned
before it's it allows you to go and take
a managed instance group and give it a
couple of images and it'll handle the
rolling update for you so in this case
we have updated from you boon to into
centos and it also has other it has an
instance group and it has an auto scalar
and so forth right so this is a tot this
H a service type is very powerful
because it basically takes in maybe
about five or six properties it takes
some auto scaling parameters give me the
lower bunk give me the upper bound give
me the pointer to your code and give me
the zones you want to run in okay and it
just spins it up for you then you can
come back to it later and you can say oh
I would like to update my running code
you can just give it a new image and the
rolling updater will update that for you
for the zone that however you want to go
and configure typically you proper do
one zone at a time but however you want
to do that so let's go back to the
slides so we have quite a few people
that have been using deploy manager for
a while and some of them really liked it
a lot so it's not just me so here are
some of our customer quotes that have
been using and building things with the
deployment manager for quite a while and
we are very happy that they are happy
because that's that's nice to hear so
deployment manager is great and really
describe to you how you can use it for
your own infrastructure but when it
comes to building solutions in the real
world there often just not using your
own software you're often using software
for mother so
how many of you use third-party software
today in your own environment pretty
much everyone exactly and this is where
Google Cloud launcher comes in just a
quick show of hands how many of you have
used launched already okay so quite a
few for those of you that haven't to
quick overview what launcher is
launchers the marketplace inside Google
cloud platform for you to get started
running third party software and
services on gcp it's integrated directly
into developers console and I'll show
you that in just a moment and it's not
just about getting simple VMs up and
running we actually have very
sophisticated solution configurations
which will show you and what that allows
you to do is not just kick the tires on
software but actually run it in
production and for especially for large
enterprises one of the big benefits here
is you get a single bill so you're using
third-party services and software but
it's all going on your single Google
bill so no more separate POS just
because you want to run MongoDB we've
grown quite a bit we have over 160
solutions from a variety of great
commercial partners I recognize most of
the names on here today and Beyond
solution growth we've actually seen
phenomenal customer adoption just over a
year ago we are between a year ago and
now we've kind of four extra grown
hundred four hundred percent which is
just outstanding and the customer
feedback has just been phenomenal we've
been hearing great feedback around
people being able to deploy solutions a
lot faster now that we have the ability
to give them third-party software
directly within the console and so I'm
going to go ahead and show you cloud
long tour in action and demonstrate some
of the integrations we've done with
deployment manager so the demo machine
so I'm just gonna switch in here
so here we are in our Google cloud
platform developers console and cloud
launcher is now integrated directly into
the menu so you click here you can find
google cloud launch right there just
takes you directly to our storefront
which allows you to browse all of the
solutions we have their categorized you
can also search the room and so i'm
going to go ahead and find let's say a
MongoDB so I see one here you can
quickly learn about what it is what it
can do for you we highlight the key
aspects that you care about like for
example what version of [ __ ] is it
running and how much is it going to cost
me in the specified configuration and we
actually expose the pricing in a very
detailed fashions we actually know what
you're paying for at the resource level
and we even show you your sustained
usage discount which I know you all love
running on Google cloud platform so
that's great so let's take now take a
look at what it looks like to deploy
MongoDB solution on Google cloud
platform in the launcher so I just click
launch and what you see is not the same
interface that you would get when you're
trying to deploy a vm what you get is
instead something very tailored tailored
specifically to to deploy [ __ ] how many
of you have deployed [ __ ] yourselves
okay how many of you enjoyed that
process nobody not a single hand exactly
totally relate to your experience this
is really where I think the power of the
launcher really shines what we have here
we're going to show you is how you can
run production configurations just by a
few clicks and a wizard so what we've
done here is we've exposed some of the
key things you'd want to configure for
[ __ ] namely server nodes and arbiter
nodes so what you can do is you can
choose your zone that's great and then
you can choose how many nodes you need
and so let's say I want to stick with
two and what we do is we have
intelligent defaults we've known we've
sort of over our experiences know what
makes sense to run different types of
software so in this case we're
suggesting using a high mmmm for vcpu
machine you can change that if you don't
like it of course but we're going to
stick with that
and a sense of running database software
you may want the extra performance you
get from running an SSD and last but not
least you probably want to control how
much storage you have attached so we
allow you to control that as well well
in any MongoDB configuration as you can
see here you have your primary you have
secondaries and then you also have this
arbiter well you want your primaries and
secondaries to be beefy but their
arbiter is not doing a whole lot of work
all it's doing is kind of being
available for heartbeats and doing some
leader election and we've captured that
concept in our configuration so what
does that mean for you that means that
you're not unnecessarily paying extra
just because you need another machine
we've instead suggested using an f1
micro the smallest into the size to run
that arbiter i'll go ahead and click
deploy and what you're going to get
taken to is the same experience that
viele just showed namely deployment
manager and so as this this week we
announced that all of the package
software solutions available in cloud
launcher are all built on deployment
manager and what that means is you get
access to all the rich resources and
templates that really just described
along with all of the power so you can
deploy once bring it down tweak some
items and now gets repeatable
deployments that you can integrate with
the rest of your software solutions so
this might take a little bit to deploy
but I deployed one earlier I was
watching another one of the sessions a
call it here these be next [ __ ] and the
things i want to highlight here are
we're not just giving you a deployment
we're not just bringing up your
infrastructure what we're actually
giving you is a single pane of
management for that infrastructure so
what do I mean by that well if you're
running MongoDB you have these primaries
and you have this arbiter one of the
first things you want to do after you
deploy this software is start using it
and so what we've done is we've bubbled
up the primary actions directly on this
page so for this MongoDB solution I see
that I can have a button that's SS aging
to the primary of the server and this is
taking advantage of our cloud SSH
feature which allows you to not have to
worry about keys everyone there's not a
single person who doesn't love this
feature I know all of you relate to it
so here we are now we're in our machine
and this is the primary so out of those
three in
and says we've already shown you how to
get exactly to where you want to be to
begin with the primary and i'm going to
show you running in action so i'm just
going to go mungo localhost and since
this is a replica set there are going to
be multiple nodes in the replica set so
let's go ahead and query the status of
that and as you can see here the replica
set is set up the way we want we have
namely a primary we have a secondary and
then we have that arbiter and what we've
done behind the scenes what I'm not
showing you is SS eating into every one
of those VMs piping IP addresses and
configuration making sure each node can
talk to each other and you've seen this
deployed in just a matter of well
seconds really it just as proof of that
a deployment I kicked off is actually up
and running and we can do the same there
let's go back to our slides here so
hopefully what we just saw is that cloud
launcher is probably easiest way to get
started especially running third party
software and services not just kick the
tires but you could actually run it in
production I've got a wide variety of
software so if you've used launcher the
past encourage you to come back in we're
constantly adding new solutions and
since it's directly integrated
developers console what's great for you
as developers is you're no more than a
few clicks away from deploying like
amazing third party packages whenever
you need to write you don't have to go
outside the console you don't have to
futz with anything outside of providers
or billing it's all integrated and last
but certainly not least is all of our
packaged software solutions as I
mentioned are now integrated directly
with deployment manager this gives you
full transparency if you messed up and
didn't like some configuration we did
for you that's fine download the
template tweak it if you want to compose
with what we did go for it you know it's
all available for you all right so
wrapping up this talk a couple things
wanted to take away first as we talked
about earlier is this notion of using
immutable infrastructure with repeatable
deployments is going to increase the
chances that is just going to work right
you're going to go from having
deployments that are snowflakes things
that you can tweaked ones may never be
able to replicate again
and just something you can stamp out
repeatedly deployment manager as we've
seen is our google cloud platform native
tool for implementing that pattern you
can deploy resources and images whether
it's VM images or containers and cloud
launched our solutions are a great way
to get started but not just to kick the
tires you can use them in production and
then start composing more sophisticated
solutions because it's the solutions are
now based on deployment manager all of
the demo code really showed you today is
available at our get up repository so I
encourage you to check it out and so
putting this all together hopefully
you've seen how we've moved from a world
of dead software deployments to living
software deployments thank you thank you
you